russell wilson one of the criticisms
from fans has been they don't use him
enough
russell wilson reiterated the sentiment
yesterday that we've heard from plenty
of people
in the media plenty of fans about how he
gets used and when he's turned loose
here's wilson talking about
that dynamic yesterday do you agree with
the sentiment that you need to be
involved
sooner and uh at a higher pace yeah i
definitely think so i mean i think the
reality is that you know early in the
games you know
you know definitely you know rather than
us having it be in the fourth quarter
i think to be able to you know make some
stuff happen i think we want to i think
we have a crazy stat of
the lead of you know i think 56-0 when
we have the lead you know and by
halftime and stuff like that i think you
know getting
getting ahead is a key thing you know i
do definitely believe in finishing
strong i think we've
been won a lot of games in the fourth
quarter and uh you know been uh
do some fun things in the fourth quarter
and in the games but um
you know let's treat every quarter as
the fourth you know and i think that's
kind of my mentality always
you know that's something that he shared
with sims and me at the super bowl
earlier this year the criticism is they
just don't they don't
know what to do with him they don't know
how to unleash him until they
have to until they're backed into a
corner
and they just basically say to russell
go save us and
look this is a even though he's got a
smile on his face the whole time
shireen this is a real pressure point
between wilson
and the coaching staff he wants an
offense
that that showcases him more not that he
needs the help
he just needs the permission he needs
the ability
it's not like he's trying to get them to
unfairly pump up his stats
he's trying to get them to just let him
be him
and this won't end well between wilson
and the seahawks
if he doesn't at some point pretty damn
soon get a chance to just go out
and do what he can do because we see
patrick mahomes doing it
we see lamar jackson doing it we see
kyler murray doing it in the same
division
russell wilson wants to be able to do it
as well not just when they need it
but all game long he's pulled a lot of
rabbits out of his hat or his helmet as
jason wooden would say
on espn's monday night football but but
he's engineered a lot of those fourth
quarter comebacks and the reason he's
done it is
they've been in the two-minute
situations where he he has control of
the offense and they need to give him
more of that control because he's shown
he's proved
he's really good at it so let him do
that in the first three quarters of the
game
get you some leads give him unleash him
give him the reins to the offense a
little bit more and hopefully they do
that this season
because i think he he's one of the best
quarterbacks in the nfl
has been since he came into the league
even as a rookie
and he just keeps getting better and
better and he talks about being in the
prime of his career he doesn't even
think he's there in the prime of his
career yet
and yet he's already as we talked about
on a hall of fame track
in his career as we are
live this friday morning currently it's
503 a.m
in the pacific it'll be 703 a.m
when these words are repeated in the
rear and this will wake up the folks in
seattle
i've said it before i'm going to say it
again there is a belief
in league circles that russell wilson
eventually will not
be playing for the seahawks now that's
not a prediction that's not a guarantee
i'm just telling you
there are people whose opinions should
not be ignored
who believe that russell wilson
eventually will be playing for another
team he's in his early 30s he said
repeatedly he wants to play until he's
45
and one of the questions in one of the
issues and one
of the realities of that relationship is
whether or not the seahawks are ever
going to use him
the way he wants to be used and not that
it's setting up for
a coup where russell demands a new coach
a new coordinator or whatever
i i think his attitude is and i'm saying
i think here i don't know but i think
his attitude is
you this is your chance do what you need
to do and at some point if you don't do
it
then we're going to work this out and
i'm going to be gone it can't happen in
the next couple of years because of cap
issues
but i'm telling you there is a real
belief
by people who are in the know
and i can't say much more than that
without compromising sources
but this idea that russell wilson is
going to be
in seattle for the rest of the decade
it's it is hardly set in stone sharing
and a lot of it depends i think
on whether or not they let him become
the patrick mahomes the lamar jackson
the kyler murray where it's not handoff
handoff handoff handoff handoff
and then oh we're down 10 points go save
our ass russell
it's more of letting him go out and do
what he does so well from start to
finish of the game
yeah and it should never come as a
surprise to any fan
or any team that that a player may not
finish
his career where he started and we saw
with peyton manning who saw tom brady
now
this year who would have thought tom
brady would ever leave new england and
yet he has he's going to finish his
career somewhere else joe montana
many many great players hall of fame
players have finished their careers
elsewhere i think russell wilson's going
to be
in the hall of fame one day he may not
finish his career in seattle
but a lot does depend on what happens
over these next few years how much
the control they do give him of the
offense and
frankly how well he plays and how many
super bowls they win
and i do think this is a super bowl team
i think they can win the super bowl this
year with with russell wilson at
quarterback i think they're going to be
competitive
every single year he's there at
quarterback for the seahawks but they've
got to do right
by him to keep him and keep him happy
and one factor that gets so overlooked
when we consider the relationship
between russell wilson and the seahawks
his agent mark rogers
has one nfl client there is no broader
dance that mark rogers has to do to try
to
maintain relationships with john
schneider the gm or pete carroll the
head coach there aren't other clients
that he currently
has with the team but he's trying to
place with the team he's trying to get
the team to draft
none of that's a concern the only
concern is doing the best deal possible
for russell wilson every chance he gets
it's no mistake it's no accident it's no
coincidence that russell wilson does
four-year extensions when everybody else
is doing five
six or if you're patrick holmes ten
years and every time it's top of the
market or close to it
he can drive a hard bargain at some
point shereen you mentioned winning
super bowls
at some point somebody in that
organization is going to say
what are we doing here we got the
highest paid quarterback in football
but we can't win super bowls because
we've got in part the highest paid
quarterback in football
we won the super bowl back when we had a
quarterback in the second year of a
third round slotted rookie deal and we
got back when he was in the third year
of a slotted third round rookie deal and
i'm
and i know i know see i know this is not
the thing you were expecting this
morning seahawks fans as you're eating
your post-toasties and drinking your
coffee
but but that is gonna be i think if it
ever falls apart
that's gonna be the way the seahawks
justify it we'll go back
to the days of having a young
quarterback on a rookie contract
and we'll be able to load the cannon
around him
and and that's how we'll win another
super bowl if they don't win one in the
next few years with russell wilson
and it's funny mike a lot of times when
teams find these quarterbacks in the
third round as they did russell wilson
fourth round dak prescott
and you look at tom brady where he was
drafted a lot of time when these teams
find those quarterbacks late they don't
use number one overall draft picks on
them
they think they can do it again they
forget all those times when they played
all those scrubbed quarterbacks and
couldn't possibly win
quarterbacks don't grow on trees
quarterbacks like russell wilson don't
go on trees you just don't go out there
and pick one
even college quarterbacks we don't know
how they're going to be even if they've
played really well in college we've seen
it over and over and over again i don't
know how much evidence you have to see
scouts do not do a good job of scouting
quarterbacks
that they don't know sometimes when
they're going to be really good like a
russell wilson and wait until the third
round to pick him and sometimes
they draft guys who are number one
overall who maybe don't pan out we've
seen that over and over and again
so they need to keep russell wilson they
need to keep russell wilson happy and
they need to give him the reins and say
take this take us to the promised land
lead us there lead us there again
yeah we know on the one yard line you
didn't make the play and that
to give us that second super bowl but
we're gonna give you another chance to
get it done
they had a decade of relative stability
with matt hasselbeck although they
they didn't get anywhere close to a
super bowl during hasselbeck's time
but a lot of quarterbacks over the years
in
seattle and when you go back and start
looking at the names and remembering the
experiences you're right
once you have that great quarterback
it's incumbent on you to try to keep him
but but if if these these little
percolating
issues oh yeah they did go to the super
bowl in 2005. what am i talking about
i forgot about that one because it was
rigged against the seahawks and the
steelers won it i'm kidding steelers
fans
how do you how do i forget super bowl
40. maybe because it was rigged against
the seahawks
anyway um they had they had a bunch of
bad quarterbacks over the years they
have a great quarterback now
and and when and how does that
relationship end
and and do we see russell wilson you
know usually it's the team that's ready
to move on
do we see russell wilson ready to move
on before the team is just something to
keep in mind
as the years unfold especially after
what he said yesterday
repeating what he said to us back in
january about wanting every quarter to
be treated like the
fourth quarter that's the closest he's
gonna come to flashing any type of
frustration he's not wired to do that
but there's something embedded deeper in
what he said that i think the seahawks
better be paying attention to
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports